he's been on the run for years namdi
kanu is the leader of a separatist group
calling for an independent state of
biafra his followers call themselves the
indigenous people of biafra
and they've not given up their dream of
their own homeland in the southeast
of nigeria the region has seen a surge
in attacks
with some 130 police officers killed
this year alone
in may nigeria security forces launched
an operation to quell the violence
which many fear may lead to a new war
but the conflict between biafran
separatists and the nigerian government
is much older than this recent outbreak
take a look at the story of one of
nigeria's most wanted fugitives
and the project that's been on pause for
more than half a century
[Music]
heavy security in abuja for the trial of
one of nigeria's most notorious
separatists
supporters of namdi kanu gathered
outside the courthouse in anticipation
there were clashes and arrests
but then mysteriously the prosecutor
failed to deliver kanu to
court said
it's a problem of logistics in simple
language
that yes i said they didn't have a
vehicle to bring him
as far as i understand the word
logistics and it did not make sense
kanu is the controversial and
charismatic founder of the indigenous
people of biafra
the group once independent from nigeria
which it says oppresses the igbo people
supporters say he's a savior
our mission is a very simple one to
restore biafra
or we die restoring death
that is why the zoo must fall
zoo is what kanu calls nigeria
his critics say he's a dangerous
nationalist in 2017
dw news sat down with him nigeria is not
a civilized country
people behave like animals they are not
reasonable enough they are not
disciplined enough they are not
mentally developed enough to run a
transparent
civil society don't you think you insult
a lot of nigerians with it
i'm being very kind to be honest i could
have used far more russia words to
describe them
the conflict between the government and
ethnic groups in south east nigeria
dates back half a century
more than two million people died during
a two-year war which began in 1967.
hundreds of thousands starved to death
nigerian president mahmoud buhari served
as a general back then
in a recent tweet he threatened to treat
the separatists
in the language they understand
for namdu kanu long a thorn in bihari's
side
that means incarceration without trial
at least for now from on these
developments
we've invited kabir adamu onto the show
he's a security analyst from beacon
consultant and joins us from abuja
hello mr damon welcome to dw news africa
now
this looks like history repeating itself
innamdi kanu was arraigned for trial in
2015.
the authorities failed to present him in
court then he was bailed and disappeared
six years later same story arrested but
not brought to court
is this legal there was an expectation
and it was stated
by the government that they will be
presenting in nandikan
in court the reason they cited for not
presenting him
is logistical and that reason has been
um sort of dispelled by
uh both sites to the extent that they
caught where the fitting held
and the location where it's been held or
at least the headquarters of the
local security department which is the
sss um
it's just a few kilometers less than 10
kilometers actually from from each other
so one really wondered what like
logistical
challenges meant when they said that was
the reason why they couldn't present it
so in summary um it's not legal in the
sense that
there was no determination by either
side
that this case would be one where the
trial would be in absentia
canoe heads the indigenous people of
biafra or ipub
how much support does the movement have
what we've seen in terms of
our observation and then the anecdotal
information that is available to us
shows that he has that the movement has
tremendous support especially among
um evils in the diaspora as well as
hebrew youths and part of the reason why
this support is not only enormous but
it's growing
it's because of the perceived and the
real
perception of marginalization that
exists within
the hebrew cultural social subgroup and
just to give a bit of perspective around
this
um the country is governed by another
knight fire northern fulani
and there is a perception among the
majority of ebos that
they have been sidelined uh infrared in
terms of infrastructure
economic empowerment financial inclusion
sometimes even social and political now
in terms of
if diaspora support we know that it has
opened accounts even in the u.s as an
example and in several
european countries where its membership
is donating money
it's also come up with some aspects of
national memorabilia
passports flag that it's selling and if
members are buying
and so these are the indications that
you see and you know it has support
but likewise if you travel to several
parts of western europe as well as
several parts of africa even
remote villages you see persons wearing
t-shirts and caps
and flags of biafra so definitely
indicating
support among these two groups that i
mentioned
so is there any chance of the nigerian
authorities
talking to the biafran or any separatist
um i think there are some backdoor
channels communication and
a very good example of this is when he
was granted bill
um it's a saving senator that you know
stood in for him
and when he jumped bill that senator was
never arrested
no sort of clarification of explanation
has been given as to why that senator
was not arrested
on the other hand you have a northern
senator
stood in for someone who is
alleged to have committed fraud and he
was arrested and kept in custody for
three years
for three days so clearly indicating
that perhaps
the government is aware of the enormous
political weight
behind this session is agitation and
i believe personally that there is some
backdoor um
communication ongoing despite the
government stands
um towards hypo okay stay with us mr
demo we have a report about similar
developments across the border in
cameroon
we'll be back with you for more on that
in a moment
those reports from cameroon indicate
english-speaking separatist militias
have joined forces with the nigerian
counterparts a development that has led
to fears of an acceleration in violence
the bathroom secessionist and the
ambassador defense force in southwestern
cameroon
share a common border and a joint
purpose to establish their own states
they say they are already sharing
weapons dw reporter laser young
reports from duala
almost three quarters of a million
people have been displaced by the
conflict
mumbai doris is one of them she says
government soldiers accuse her entire
village
of supporting the separatists and touch
their homes has included
for the last four years she has been
staying with her children at this
rundown property in the town of kumba
they burnt down the entire village and
we hid out in the forest
but it was full of mosquitoes we didn't
have much to eat and we only had dirty
water to drink
i made up my mind to leave and seek
refuge in the city
since the start of 2017 cameron's
government has deployed thousands of
troops
to push back anglophone separatists the
militias are fighting to create a
breakaway state they call
ambassador and they are looking for new
ways to extend their influence
in april this year a faction of the
cessationist movement announced a
cross-border partnership
with nigerian securities group the
indigenous people of biafra
about the alliance between the governing
council military win the edf
and the ipod the indigenous people of
biafra it has
given the ambassador defense forces
unprecedented access to unlimited supply
of ammunition
from the black market within the
nigerian area
and it has also allowed our forces and
both the forces of the eastern security
network safe
heavens across the border dw news africa
contacted the cameroonian army
a military spokesman declined to comment
camp caving works for a local human
rights organization
they have been documenting the conflict
in cameroon he says attacks from
secretaries have increased since their
partnership with the biafrans
recently we have seen after the
collaboration
how the service fighters have
grown from strength to strength they
have been
a wide use of improvised explosive
devices
on the side of the separatists and this
has led to the killing of
so many defense and security forces as
compared to
the previous years this intensification
is bad news for doris
she says she would love to return to her
village but she can't because of the
ongoing fighting
their lands between anglophone
separatists and the biafrans
is only expected to further worsen the
conflict in the cameroonian side
so doris won't be going back home
anytime soon
kabir adamu is still with us he's a
security analyst in abuja nigeria mr amu
separatists in biafra and ambassador
announced their cooperation
earlier this year do we know how
extensively they are working together
the in the announcement they indicated
that the
corporation would run across a couple of
areas
one of them is them weapon you know
acquisition and sharing
the other one is training for their
members and then they also mentioned the
protection of their
common borders now we know that the
gun running channels in nigeria are
quite extensive
and giving nigeria sort of proximity
especially in this in this instance
access to uh weapons that have that have
sort of fed
the militants in the niger delta as well
as the
um outcome of the collapse of um qadhafi
in libya and the weapons that have flown
into the sahel that are finding their
way
into the niger delta area and of course
into eastern nigeria
so it's likely that um in terms of
weapon exchange
uh both groups would it would be sort of
a strategic
sort of partnership that would benefit
um both groups
um we also know for instance that in
terms of
their mobilization the negative the
negative
sort of narrative they put out there
against the central government of either
country
and they use the mobilization strategic
partnership
um build around this negative um you
know marginalized
uh cry of marginalization would help
both sides
an alliance sounds definitely like a big
deal what impact could this alliance
have on
regional stability for instance
a lot if we see the nigeria as the
regional
superpower and the fact that it already
has
a huge task addressing the
insurgency the region in the
lecture basin area now with another
front opening in
the southeast let's remember that from
the beginning of this year
uh ipop or some affiliates have been
attacking
security forces formations with a
ferocity that is
indicative of an upcoming insurgency and
now
if that partnership or alliance grows
and we now
see a new front in terms of an
insurgency in both
the southeast of nigeria and in southern
cameroon
then uh their capacity of nigeria to
remain at the regional superpower
and assist in containing some of the
challenges within the sub-region would
be
reduced tremendously because it will be
dealing with its own
internal problems which unfortunately do
exist at the moment
and they are growing at very worrisome
state
trying to wrap it up i wish we had more
time but the use of brutal force against
the separatist
and occasional rare dialogues haven't
stopped the cause for more autonomy
so what is the best way to tackle this
situation
i could tell you two words and then say
thank you and leave and that's good
governance
if there will be an improvement in
governance to address the root causes of
um this growing call for cessation
um then um hopefully this would reduce
um
in in the nigerian case and in fact even
in the cameroonian case
a recognition by the central government
of some of the grievances a good example
is um
a recognition that this number of people
died
during the biafran war in 1967 to 1970
as well as in the case of cameroon and
perhaps the declaration of a national
holiday
around that period and some form of
political action
to show recognition engagement as well
as to address
the concerns around inclusion diversity
as well as
the feeling of marginalization i think
would go a long way towards reduce
reducing the agitation that's against
the use of brutal force
kabu adamu security analyst in abuja
thanks for your insights
thank you for having me
as we just heard one way to defuse the
crisis in nigeria
would be good governance yet for some in
the region it was
actually the election of president
muhammadu buhari himself a veteran of
the biafran war
that reawakened calls for independence
now the arrest of namdi kanu has only
heightened tensions
we sent west africa correspondent fred
mouvony to biafra to meet a veteran of
the war
who wants to avoid a return to conflict
ghosts of war are easily found in
biafran
sasakaru's rebel unit captured and
used an armored car like this during the
war he
is still haunted
wickedness black man against black man
hatred before you kill somebody you must
hate the person
passionately i mean they slaughtered
these people
the weapons which crashed the
independence movement
killing millions of people are now in
this museum
this museum behind me keeps the memory
of what the people of biafra
went through so many years ago it's been
five decades
now and the desire of having an
independent state of biafra
is still fresh
veteran says more than 50 years after
the war
the region is worse off than before
you can smell poverty baby and i don't
know about lagos i don't know about
abuja i'm talking about
but where i live it's poverty
it's not just poverty abject poverty
people here are accompanied by the
ghosts of war
it's difficult to know how many people
want independence
a government crackdown makes talking
about it
a frightening prospect
this man leads a coordination of youth
leaders
in the region he says the way to silence
cause for beautiful and independence
is for nigeria to elect an evil
president
we have people who have given the
opportunity
that will turn the economy of the entire
country to be
a super and developed economy so
we want power so that we can tell
nigerians
that we have what it takes to make
things right
both these men want change in biafra
but their hopes for an independent
biafra are considered
far-fetched by many analysts
it's this generation who make the next
crucial moves the war stopped then
i didn't continue we thank god for that
but
now there are instabilities we hope for
stabilities i think people should
tolerate each other they should be
tolerant like tolerates other people's
individual differences
so that war does not sprinkle during
that time
starvation was as it speaks many
nigerians many biafrans died at that
time
so in spite of the instability war is
never an option
the veteran gives a voice to the ghosts
and he talks to the young
a good time their understanding of what
happened before
will affect how they shape the future
you